[Music]
and bad pr move
news going along right now yeah i feel
like no one has a good pr
no one does true it's just the way the p
is submitted by spider cookies what the
[ __ ] no [ __ ] no
spider-shaped cookies what if they're
spider-shaped [ __ ] no they have those
little googly eyes yeah
no they're wafers where's their wafers
spider wafers with strawberry in the
middle
then you admit their cookies [ __ ] yeah
oh
whoa no i said whatever over dudes will
never die that's great i said what if
and i like how you jump to conclusions
you don't think waivers are wafers or
cookies
i do not believe they're cookies you're
on our side
um i i uh i don't i don't like this
anymore i don't like it anymore
i think we need to i think we need to
bring in butler
to figure it out yeah right the cookies
are not they don't know what they don't
get the joke they don't
have to watch on the video well we don't
want mrs fields to talk about cookies we
know that we want some random celebrity
to talk about that's all you're saying
yeah yeah yeah public backlash ensues
after twitch streamer admits he has a
god complex
at least he admitted it a lot of people
have that what's god complex
like you think every youtuber i know
better than every other book this
video is one of the most hilarious
things ever only because
the person that's saying it is hideous
it's like
it's not people shouldn't be offended it
should be you should laugh at it
because he looks like he smells like top
ramen you know what i mean
like top ramen and like anime episodes
is what he looks like okay and like the
dude's like
i'm better than you really like like
flat out
when i saw the video i was in tears
laughing because i was like i don't
think you realize
who you are that's a show i've always
wanted to see is where you get really
wealthy people to tell
the american public and the world why
they're better than you i don't even
think he's like super popular right i
don't know because i've never heard him
before either but he's small time
i love his friends reactions around him
because they're all like
sitting next to him and they're just
like
sort of like joking like ah that's not
very you probably shouldn't say that
you know that you're like like that it's
like that one kid in like your in your
high school
that one black dude that wore like the
dragon ball z t-shirt oh yeah right yeah
yeah then he has like a [ __ ] not a
toe headband
he's running down the halls like this
hey i'm way hotter than all of you
that's what i wish warren buffett would
do he's like he's like it's like how did
you do it warren and he's like i'm
better than you guys man i don't know
i'm just
for me i'm like yes yeah i'm like
i agree right yeah so this guy his name
is michael
he goes by um dust and
his career disgust so he is known for
speed running resident evil 7
just that game he currently holds the
world records for beating that game as
quickly as possible
and he's got a god complex what about
resident evil 8 bro he's like well you
know
it looks like going to like michael it's
a harder game
all right okay yeah so
i'll show you guys the clip that went
viral i think you think he's uglier
because he's a prick about it he's not
like a [ __ ] hideous person
maybe from what i saw from the video he
looked like a little greasy lip [ __ ]
he looks like a regular guy yeah he does
he's a weirdo i didn't see him close but
i just saw that one
he looks like a weeb dude you know what
he looks like he looks like isaac like
10 years from now
look at that does look like isaac my
baby is way cuter well no i better you
know you can see it in the face right i
mean it does look like
isaac yeah not funny and the shape the
shape of the
david you want to retract uh your
earlier car oh no i never take back a
joke
double jump i'm gonna tell isaac queen i
love isaac
all right so this is what david she
still didn't take it back
i love it this is the video that went
viral here we go
when i look for streamers that i i want
to rely on she makes me laugh too i want
them to be witty i want them to be cool
i want them to have that unique aspect
that all of us strive to have um but i
need there to be a little bit of a
relationship because i don't want to
talk to a [ __ ] wall
okay but well part of the thing for me
is is i specifically don't want
my viewers to have any kind of
relationship with me so like that's like
it kind of works out right i'm kind of
like i'm hitting my goal
but um no you totally are yeah
and as weird as that sounds and it's
like it's kind of like low-key like god
complex kind of thing is
i don't feel like many of my viewers
should relate themselves to me because
and this is like super like kind of like
i got comp
like kind of weird it's like i do think
of myself as better than
or not better but like better this is
going so
there's no good way to say this i think
of myself as like above the average
person so i don't feel like yes
it relates to me as bad as that sounds i
know
but like i love him i love this guy
at least he doesn't just sit there and
act like he's better he says he thinks
he's better
you know his position right away yeah i
like that i love that i
really wish like a youtuber would do
that too right i wish [ __ ] jim
parsons from big bang theory would be
like
i'm just better than everybody but even
jip parsons i believe it just because he
makes
[ __ ] 20 million dollars a year so i'm
like yeah
so why are people mad this video
obviously
it's like just a short portion of the
entire panel
and what was happening here was how
he was explaining how he takes a
different approach
to twitch because almost everybody the
way they approach
twitch is like i'm gonna build a
relationship with my
viewers i'm gonna you know connect with
them i want them to see me as someone
that's their friend that could be their
friend in real life
and that's pretty much every single
social influence and so
he the way he does it it's more like
look
i don't want you to relate to me i don't
want any sort of like false friendship
happening between us
even in his like uh frequently asked
questions
it says um like you know i prefer those
who don't know me personally to just
call me
dust because i don't feel comfortable
being called by my birth name from those
who i don't know on twitch
he never does any giveaways he doesn't
want
viewers that only see him for the
giveaways like he just wants people like
listen like he's just very like
too authentic right this is about the
game this is not about me
i don't want to sell you my personality
it's just if you're going to watch me
play video games and that's what i'm
going to give you and he's just very
upfront about that
and what's wrong with that well no he's
lifting up a leg and [ __ ] on his fan
saying like hey i'm up
here and you are down there yeah and so
don't even look in my eyes
yeah i'm up here that's how he came out
right
but then what um this article is saying
that this was after
like about an hour of like dealing with
all these people's questions
and like telling them like how he's
wrong for the way he views things yeah
and so this was just like
towards the end of his panel because it
was the last question yeah
and he was saying like you know he
approached it obviously
poorly and that he was just really
nervous he's never been oh he's a little
[ __ ] now
because for me it's like if you think
you're a god [ __ ] it just own it
you [ __ ] [ __ ] on your fans and if
they all
end up unsubscribing then that's just
part of the consequence he did back
pedal because he was saying like it's
not that i think that i'm better than
any other human that's not what i meant
he's like i've just been struggling with
self-conscious or like self-esteem
issues and he's like whenever what you
said though
what you said but let me let me clarify
this i don't like them anymore you
literally said god complex and i'm
better twice
yeah that complex twice there's no
misinterpretation
yeah for sure i'm just telling you what
here yeah yeah i'm saying he was saying
because he did this whole like twit
longer
thing yeah it's like this long-ass thing
and at the end of it it says like too
long didn't read
the tl dr right here it says
this past weekend i made a fool of
myself and grossly misspoke
i was a part of what i said was
absolutely garbage and i made it
horrible oh you're such a puss now being
in streaming communities i'm so
i'm sorry for not better preparing
myself for the panel being a jackass
with
how i chose to respond to it prior to
now so please refer to me as dust and
not justin thank you
you know what i mean like come on man he
was also saying like back to that whole
thing about how he struggles and stuff
he
for himself to overcome that in his own
mind
he would tell him like you know you're a
guy if he wanted to cheat on a meal or
didn't want like didn't work out or
whatever he's like no you're better than
that like you're better than this like
you're better than other people you're
the best so he was like building yeah so
he's still happy well he still has that
oh i get what he's saying he's just
dumb look i don't give a [ __ ] where the
pain comes
from you can't like you if you smack me
in the face i still think you suck
yeah like give me a break man and i see
where he's talking about like he's been
dealing with
quests because she's very coming off as
very combative when she's asking that
question about like oh like you should
have a relationship with your fans and
stuff which i don't think you should
have to do i think you should be able to
do his twitch stream however you want
yeah if he wants to do it from a god
complex go ahead well this chick is
trying to tell him why she doesn't watch
him but yeah
and that's fine but he shouldn't say
like oh i'm better than you he should be
like that's just not how i want to run
my stream
he's like hey uh he had been saying that
though no
and i get why but still he can't you
can't but even even if he does say he's
better
to me that's completely cool just own it
like for example i wouldn't be surprised
if
prince thought he was just above
everyone else he's just like at a
completely different level
and if he owned it who cares like i'm
sure a lot of like high level
celebrities think that way
oh yeah look at paisley park it was a
[ __ ] mega church you know
yeah for prince for the for the worship
of prince
but um no but what you're saying i think
it's a really good point because
for example the the basic audience
person who watches
all of us there's i've run into people
who are like you know why i don't watch
you man like [ __ ] like that where it's
like
i don't give a [ __ ] like you're not
entitled to control my creativity
especially when it comes off like that
like it's not even constructive
criticism
it's just like yeah it's just like hey
[ __ ] you and it's like no just like
don't watch my [ __ ] then and that's what
she was doing she's like i don't wanna
look at a wall and so he's like okay
well i already obviously have an
audience i'm up here
so you don't want to watch me that's
cool is that okay
he was also saying he's like what i was
really saying was that i don't
want my viewers to relate to me because
i am so far from where i want to be and
that's kind of the minute that's not
what you were saying
i don't like this kid now like at first
i thought it was very entertaining and
i'm like
now it's just like oh you're just being
a little puss now now he's like i
[ __ ] up what can i do you you
literally feel like you're better than
these people and you should just stuck
to that and then just see what happens
but now you're worried about your
paycheck
because even for me like i told you guys
even off camera like i had this whole
situation where
i i kind of like this girl got really
offended apologized to her because she
felt bad
but i also said i'm not taking the joke
back yeah get out of it i still gotta
stand by my guns but i
if i hurt somebody's feelings like to
the point where they felt like
diminished as a human being that i'm
like okay
that wasn't the point of the joke so
that means my joke missed too yeah and i
had a girl reach out to me and she was
very
offended that i sometimes used the word
[ __ ] which i was called as a young boy
in my very as we all were as we all were
and so i was like you know i use
i use the word because i uh i don't
think it just belongs to one category of
people i don't think the gay people are
[ __ ] either so
i'm sorry that you do and then she she
was like well that's really offensive
that i don't think the gay people are
[ __ ] and i was like well i just think
that you should stop being a [ __ ]
and that was it never heard from her
again but but you know what i mean like
i don't like all this apology video [ __ ]
i think we should ban all apology videos
from the internet
because like you said what you meant
like leave it at that like what does
it say what you mean when you say yes
but then also try to listen
i i also i'm of two minds of it where
i'm like
if you say something and then you're
misinterpreted for what you said and
then you clarify what you said and
people like nah you only meant the first
thing
that could be a little mean too i think
clarifying is cool because sometimes
things are taken out of context yeah but
i don't think people should apologize
that's what happened to my
my [ __ ] was taken out of context and
there there wasn't any
it wasn't i mean obviously a majority of
people were on my side and the reason
why i
i didn't take down the video instagram
took it down for me which i was kind of
pissed i was gonna leave it up there
just to be spiteful
but but the thing i got upset about was
that uh
the reason why i had apologized to her
because when
other people in the comments were kind
of getting on her and i was like uh see
now
now that's not a joke wait fill me in i
don't even know what happened it's just
a long story i don't want to get the
word
it's not a big thing so either way like
people the joke wasn't coming across
where they weren't laughing they were
laughing at her and they weren't
laughing with her
so that's when i felt bad i was like ah
she's not a part of the joke now
now she's just the butt of the joke and
i'm like uh that i was supposed to be
the butt of the joke
so that's why i apologize to her yeah
welsh
she was being a loose woman i think
[Music]
one